as actors we show up we work hard and
hopefully we take our job seriously
without taking ourselves too seriously
and seriously
shelli's - uncle kick my ass we aspire
to transform ourselves into the
characters we play and to transport the
movie goer in the process among a sea of
brilliant performances each year certain
of them stand out for their artistry
their honesty and the masterful choices
made in interpreting the role we honor
those individuals tonight here are the
nominees for performance by an actor in
a supporting role Mahalo Ali green Adam
driver black lands
Sam Elliott the star deepu Richard II
grunt Buster goes to rehearsal
[Applause]
this is the second pasta and second
nomination from a perch lolly he took
home his first Oscar in this category
for moonlight
[Applause]
Academy thank you
well think dr. Shirley for just trying
to capture his essence trying to capture
dr. Shirley's essence pushed me to my my
ends and which is a reflection of the
person he was and the life that he lived
and I thank him I think my partner of
ego with him Peter Farrelly a thank you
for your leadership and your guidance
and and for also given a space like
really given a space to work it out and
and coming in and tweaking and really
appreciate and love you Octavia Spencer
[Applause]
Chris Bowers my double I want to I want
to dedicate this to to my grandmother
who has been in my ear my entire life
telling me that if I first I don't
succeed try try again that I could do
anything I put my mind to always always
pushing me to think positively and I
know that I would not be here without
her that she has gotten me over the hump
every step of the way I think my wife
and my daughter Bari
I thank universal participant ambling
everyone who contributed and helped with
our movie again thank you so much